One of the big
difficulties students
have in a problem that
involves many objects is
to successfully identify
third law interaction pairs.
So today, I'd like to look
at a problem which shows us
how to think about that.
So what we're going to look at
is third law interaction pairs.
Now, the problem I'd like to
consider is the following.
Suppose we have a block one
and another block two sitting
on block one on a surface
and our surface has friction.
And I'd like to push
block one with a force F.
And now I'd like to use
Newton's second law to determine
what is the maximum force I can
push that block two will not
slip.
So I'm trying to find F max such
that block two does not slip.
Now, how do we even begin
to think about this?
Well, the first thing
that we have to decide
is when we apply Newton's second
law, our first question will
be, what is the system
that we'll choose?
And in this problem, there
are three separate ways
to think about this.
Just to show you an example,
so system a will be block one,
system b will be block
two, and system c
will be block one and block two.
And given these
different systems,
I can address
different questions
and we'll see that
as we develop this.
So let's start with
block one and we'll
start with breaking our
problem down into block one
and block two.
And let's draw the free-body
diagrams on those blocks,
trying to identify
action-reaction pairs.
So let's begin with block one.
First off, we know there's
gravitational force
and the Earth is the other pair
there, which we're not drawing.
There's friction
between the surfaces.
So there's a friction between
the ground and block one.
There is the normal force
of the ground on block one.
Block two is
sitting on block one
so there's a normal force
of block two on block one.
And finally, as
you push block one,
there's a friction
force between block two
and block one that's opposing
the fact that block one is
being pushed forward.
So we have a friction force
here between blocks two and one.
Now, this friction
down here is kinetic.
But if the blocks
are moving together,
this friction here is static.
So those are the free-body
force diagrams on one.
I'll choose unit
vectors in a moment.
Now, what about two?
So let's draw two.
Well, again, m2 g-- the
Earth is the other element
of the interaction pair.
And now, block one is
pushing block two up.
So we have block one pushing
block two up and notice
our indices make it very easy
to see that our first Newton's
third law interaction pair is
the normal force of contact
between the two blocks.
Now, what else?
Here's the subtle thing is
that this whole system will
move to the right.
What's the force that's making
block two move to the right?
Well, it's static friction.
So static friction from
block one and block
two-- this is the
static friction--
is causing block two
to move to the right.
And now we can see, again our
third law interaction pair.
So in this problem, we have
two third law pairs, this one
and I'll connect the line there,
and those are the third law
pairs.
Now, we know by the third law
that they're equal and opposite
in magnitude.
We can identify f.
We can call this one
N if we wanted just
to save ourselves the problem
of writing a lot of indices.
Once we've done that,
we're now ready to apply
Newton's second law.
We haven't yet figured
out what the condition is
that it will just slip.
We'll get to that.
But for the moment, we can now
apply vector decomposition.
So we need to choose
some unit vectors.
Because I'm pushing the system
this way, it makes sense for me
to choose my i-hat to the right.
So here, I'm going to
choose i-hat 1 and j-hat 1.
Now, over here, I could
choose the same unit vectors,
even though I'm
thinking about this
as a completely separate problem
with its own coordinate system.
And I'll choose
i-hat 2 and j-hat 2.
But because these unit vectors
are in the same direction,
they're equal.
And they're both moving in
the positive i directions
and so I expect both a1
and a2 to be positive.
And now I on block one, I can
write down F1 equals m1 a1.
And because we have two
different directions,
I'll separate out.
I like to call this
my "scorecard."
And now I look at the forces.
Oh, I missed the pushing force.
But that's an
interesting exercise.
When I looked at
this diagram, I saw
I had two forces going this way.
I had no force acting that way.
I went back.
I checked my free-body
diagram, and recognized
that I forgot to put
F in there-- always
a good exercise to double-check
your free-body diagrams
before you apply Newton's laws.
So now in the x-direction,
we have the pushing force
minus the static
friction minus-- we'll
call this fk-- minus
the kinetic friction
and that's equal to m1 a1.
Now in the vertical
direction, we
have the ground
friction, N ground
1, minus block two
pushing down on block one
minus the gravitational force.
And there is no acceleration
in that direction.
And I double-check my free-body
diagrams, I check my signs,
and that looks right to me.
Now, for block two, I'll
apply the same analysis.
F2 equals m2 a2.
Separate out my two
unit directions.
Notice even though these
unit vectors are the same,
I'm emphasizing that I'm
talking about block two.
I could have chosen different
coordinate systems if I wanted.
Now, I look at my
free-body diagrams.
On block two.
I see that its
static friction is
the only one in the
positive i-hat direction.
So I have F equals m2 a2.
And in the vertical
directions, I
have that my force between
the blocks, the normal force
between the blocks,
minus gravity is 0.